we are being dehumanized so we're not
real people and
and because of our point of view they're
already talking about you know
uh no medical care we shouldn't be in
society i mean it's it's it's exactly
what happened
in the 1930s in other places um
it just happens to be that
it's the political point of view now
that's not acceptable and what's scary
is 57 percent
um of democrats say
it's 48 i think that say you shouldn't
have your children if you won't get them
vaccinated and 57 say maybe we should
put you in a camp
that's terrifying
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of the glenn beck program and
the author of the great reset joe biden
and the rise of 21st century fascism
glenn beck welcome back to the reuben
report thank you very much dave how are
you
i'm just fine my friend you have
recouped from kovid people were you know
celebrating your demise they know
everybody
i know i was on the levin show and he
said how you feeling and i said it other
than having covid in my
you know and uh and the country being
destroyed i'm good
and he was like wait do you have covid
and i'm like yeah no big deal uh it's
going into my lungs now which it always
does and i wasn't free i kept saying i'm
not freaked out i'm not freaked out it's
no big deal it's no big deal oh my gosh
the world was like set on fire
glenn beck has coveted he should die
it was bizarre glenn why is it maybe you
can explain this to me you know a bit
about my political evolution why is it
that every time one of my friends get
covered you dennis prager people want
them to die why is that you guys are
good people as far as i'm concerned am i
missing something glenn
i think because
the um and it's happening to the right
too
we are being dehumanized so we're not
real people and
and because of our point of view they're
already talking about you know
uh no medical care we shouldn't be in
society i mean it's it's it's exactly
what happened
in the 1930s in other places um
it just happens to be that it's the
political point of view now that's not
acceptable and what's scary is 57
percent
um of democrats say
it's 48 i think that say you shouldn't
have your children if you won't get them
vaccinated and 57 say maybe we should
put you in a camp
that's terrifying terrifying
so that that kinda is what the book is
about to some extent because it's it's
about that there has been a move on all
of us and our freedoms for quite some
time i want to show the cover again here
and we'll put up a proper image as well
because it's a scary cover these faces
these are these are three scary which
one of these people it's it's soros for
me for sure out of klaus schwab soros
and and biden
when you see immediately seems like the
scariest one like you wouldn't want to
see him in a dark alley yeah no i think
he i mean he looks and more and more
every day like the emperor first he
looks like palpatine yeah um so i think
the scariest to me is soros he has
believe it or not
um kind of the least to do with the
actual
uh verbiage in the book but he is the
guy who started the wef with klaus
schwab um klaush is the guy who is
really pushing it but without soros
there wouldn't be a place to push it and
without soros it wouldn't be being
pushed he is a huge force
the other one is joe biden who
uh has bought into this 100
and is on the road uh to
to transform
not just america but the entire western
world in ways that will affect your life
that you can't even imagine yet when you
get to the end of the book you'll
realize
everything is about to change how i eat
how i dress
what i say
how i pick my job do i get to pick my
job my kids in school
they're going to be fast-tracked will
they get to pick their own career
everything is changing so when you say
this you obviously are talking about the
great reset which was a phrase that if
we were to utter
say a year ago people would say you were
conspiracy theorists but as everyone
knows yesterday's conspiracy theorist is
now today's truth teller you've been
warning about sort of all of this stuff
forever i think the first time that we
sat down which is probably about five
years ago now i said i used to watch you
on fox you'd have the board behind you
and i'd go and you'd be scribbling all
this stuff and running across the room
and the whole thing and i'd be going
this guy is half genius half crazy half
entertainer and i know that that's three
halves but there was just a lot there
but you have you really have been sort
of tracking all of this from the
financial system to the political system
and everything else so i guess where did
you like in retrospect i suppose looking
back now do you see a moment when you
first started putting the pieces
together for some of this stuff uh yeah
so i started first starting putting the
pieces together and i didn't know what i
was dealing with up until about a year
and a half ago i mean i thought we were
dealing with socialists and
we're not the socialists are being used
anybody who's a marxist boy are you
going to be pissed when when they
finally show up yeah um it is that is
cover to hide what's really going on and
i didn't figure that one out but i do
remember
sitting in my studio in radio city and i
was getting ready to do a show
and there was a
little article i mean it was literally i
mean just a few paragraphs
in the wall street journal buried and it
was about a
uh
one of the congressmen
uh introducing and then them passing
this bill that you could not take your
money out of the united states with you
and i thought
hmm
somebody knows something is coming
somebody knows i mean we've never had a
problem with exodus of money what is
that uh and that's when i first started
going wait a minute what's going on and
then i realized
that
when they say they want to make the
world fair and equitable
it was about 2007 or 8 that i realized
well you can't do that you can't bring
the rest of the world up to the united
states because we've tried
and it's getting better
but it's not up it's not up to parity so
the easy thing to do is bring the united
states down to everybody else's level
and that's what we're doing
so let's talk about the joe biden part
of this because i want to talk about
sort of the machine behind it but let's
just get to like the parts that i think
are a little more easy for people to
understand first on the joe biden part
do you think biden is fully aware of
what he is part of like the the sort of
year you think he is that in this last
year the level of destruction that has
been brought across this country supply
chain inflation the whole shebang
afghanistan everything
i'm not sure
i'm not sure he understands the impact
but he does he is fully aware and and
and committed
to the direction
i don't know how much he sees of the
wreckage
but he is committed to the direction and
and i say that because his first speech
in front of congress remember he got in
it was about a month later and it was
kind of a state of the union thing
and if you knew what you were looking
for
it was terrifying terrifying
he started when he came in and remember
they were all sitting like six feet
apart and so not everybody was there and
he said you are the ones and i remember
thinking he's at first he's looking at
the camera and talking to us and he's
like you are the ones and then he
started pointing and looking at all the
people in congress that have saved the
world and you are the ones here that
made things happen he wasn't talking to
the american people he was talking to
the elites in that room
the next thing he said and he said it
twice
plus he briefed the news anchors
prior to the speech on what he was going
to talk about and the real problem in
america and he said it twice in the
speech he said you know
we have to decide whether our system of
government can um
compete
with these new authoritarian governments
like china
and the jury's still out
well
he said before the speech that
he still bet non-america but
i don't know if it's going to survive it
has to dramatically change so they are
what they put together literally is the
definition of fascism
forget about the jack boots forget about
what you think that means
look at the real definition that is a
public-private partnership with private
businesses and if you're in the party or
you're doing what the party wants you to
do you're fine the minute you're not
you're out whether that is you know a a
slave camp or you're just out kicking
rocks that's what's happening in china
and china is the model here if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell